in our last lecture we looked at how the
city of philadelphia coped with the
deadly second wave of the 1918 flu
in our final lecture on the flu we'll
see how the lingering effects of the flu
helped set the stage for world war
ii and we'll follow modern medical
detectives as they race to recover the
virus
and learn its secrets
as the end of world war one approached
rumors of armistice began to fly
but president woodrow wilson was
determined to fight to the death
and concede nothing to the aggressors
wilson proclaimed that
to fight you must be brutal and ruthless
force
forced to the utmost force without stint
or limit
the righteous and triumphant force that
will make right the law of the world
and cast every selfish dominion down in
the dust
president wilson met with lloyd george
and clemens so in paris in early 1919
to work out the terms of surrender the
third wave of the flu was just hitting
paris at that time
with flu-related deaths back up to 2676
in february and one of those victims was
wilson's daughter
one of wilson's aides writes there seems
to be millions of throat germs going
around and a number of diplomats have
lost their voices altogether
the old world is badly germ ridden it is
soaked with disease on thursday
april 3rd wilson was struck by a
coughing spell so severe he had
difficulty breathing
and the attack was so sudden that dr
carrie grayson wilson's white house
physician
at first thought that wilson had been
poisoned
he was very ill severe diarrhea had a
fever over 103 degrees
he lay in bed for several days couldn't
even sit up until the fourth day
george and clem also came to wilson's
room to continue the talks
but the talks went very poorly
wilson was gaunt and haggard had a pale
face and sunken eyes but he continued to
drive himself relentlessly
herbert hoover grew concerned that
wilson had changed after his illness
becoming stubborn unwilling to listen to
advice
secret service agent colonel starling
noted that wilson
lacked his old quickness of grasp and
tired easily
wilson became paranoid insisting that
his home was filled with french spies
he grew obsessed with the most trivial
details like
who was using what official vehicle
lloyd george refers to wilson's nervous
and spiritual breakdown
in the middle of the conference
attributing it to overwork and harsh
criticism
by the press in gilbert close wilson's
secretary writes
i never knew the president to be in as
difficult a frame of mind as he is now
even while lying in bed he manifested
peculiarities
and then wilson suddenly announced a
complete change of face
conceding to clemmons so virtually every
point that he had previously fought
so hard to make later authorities
speculated that wilson had suffered a
mild stroke
ignoring his bout of flu and that stroke
is an idea that persists to this day
and for good reason we don't normally
associate flu with neurological or
psychological problems
but the 1918 flu that was the exception
to the general rule
it left many of its victims with
permanent mental damage
dr charles w burr a specialist in mental
complications from influenza
wrote back in 1918 that the typical flu
survivor
might face some long-term mental
problems
quote to make a decision about some
trifling matter tires him
and an important matter requiring any
deep thought for even a short time
must be put to one side so
did wilson's concessions result from his
struggle with influenza
a careful examination of his state of
mind before and after the flu
strongly suggests that his illness
changed his attitude and behavior
profoundly
whatever the cause by caving into
clemenceau's harsh treatment of germany
wilson helped to create the conditions
that ultimately led to the next world
war
adolf burl jr later to be appointed
assistant secretary of state
says in his letter of resignation to
wilson
i'm sorry that you did not fight our
fight to the finish and that you had
so little faith in the millions of men
like myself
in every nation who had faith in you
our government has consented now to
deliver the suffering peoples of the
world to
new oppressions subjections and
dismemberments
a new century of war
well between adding to the miseries of
the first world war and contributing to
the rise of the second world war
the 1918 flu had a big impact on human
history
what if it were to return today would we
be prepared to fight it
one of the most fascinating aspects of
the 1918 flu
turns out to be a detective story the
search in modern times for an intact
virus
and that search is no idle exercise
because in the wrong hands
the virus could make a formidable weapon
but if we can find one maybe we can
figure out why it was so incredibly
deadly
and if we can decode its genes we might
find a way to fight it or
any similar virus we're more vulnerable
today than our parents were
in so many ways we've made all of these
great advancements in public health and
medical technology but
recent changes in lifestyle and diet
have left us a lot closer to the brink
should that deadly flu be unleashed in
our lifetime
think about how quickly the 1918 flu was
spread by rail and ocean liner
our modern network of interstate
highways and global airlines would
disperse a killer like that a lot faster
and more effectively and our
increasingly interconnected global trade
system is also more easily disrupted
we're less self-reliant economically
speaking
so a global pandemic might trigger a
cascade of economic collapse
leading to shortages of critical items
and our growing reliance on refrigerated
and frozen food
means that our homes contain a
significantly greater amount of
perishable items
remember how philadelphia's stores
closed down as the flu began to spread
with a minimum of canned goods and dry
food in our pantries most of us would
soon run
out go back to 1957
a typical american family ate about 90
percent of their meals at home
their kitchen contained only about 20
percent perishable foods
mostly different kinds of fresh fruits
and vegetables
the modern american household eats at
home only 62
percent of the time and 48 percent of
the food
in the typical home consists of
perishable food
let's face it if mcdonald's and burger
king were to close tomorrow
a significant portion of my immediate
family would probably starve to death
within a month
so being more vulnerable means we have
to be better prepared
and that preparation starts with a
better understanding of what made this
flu virus
so dangerous but where to begin
few samples were preserved at the time
people didn't really know what viruses
were much less how to save them
so how to find a sample of the deadly
virus
well the answer is simple look in the
lungs of the dead
the us army had preserved many samples
of lung tissue from dead soldiers
soaking them in formaldehyde and
encasing them in little squares of
paraffin
in fact the original orders to preserve
tissues from diseased military personnel
came from none other than abraham
lincoln
jeffrey taubenberger of the armed forces
institute of pathology
along with his colleague ann reed began
trying to isolate the virus from a scrap
of lung tissue that they
took from a young soldier meanwhile
dr kirsty duncan anthropologist
geographer
amateur virologist had become obsessed
with solving the mystery
and she reasoned that only burial and
permafrost would have saved that 1918
virus
that long a four year search led her in
1997
to a little frozen cemetery in
spitsbergen
a tiny windswept aisle some 600 miles
north of northern norway and there had
been several coal mines on the island
active in the early 1900s
operated by the arctic coal company
now duncan knew that the flu had hit
norway and she wondered if any miners
had carried it to spitsbergen
she finally narrowed her search to the
mining town of longier bien which was a
seasonal mining town
you fished in the spring you mined for
coal in the winter
most of the local records had been
destroyed in world war one
but she finally managed to track down
some old company diaries
held by a local school teacher and using
those diaries
she found a cemetery with six young
miners from norway who had died of the
flu
just after leaving the ship and were
buried in the frozen soil
as she was assembling an expedition to
exhume the bodies taubenberger was
closing in on the prize
he contacted duncan and the two of them
actually collaborated for a while but
they very soon parted company duncan
found taubenberger and reed to be too
cautious too
methodical and taubenberger found duncan
to be much too flamboyant
expedition prepared to don moon suits to
prevent the release of live virus but
that elaborate exhumation proved a
complete bust
the bodies turned out to be buried too
close to the surface and were badly
decayed
keep an eye out for reruns of virus a
1995 nbc tv movie which is based on a
robin cook novel
and features a fictional kirsty duncan
type racing to unearth the 1918 bug
in order to fight a modern epidemic
meanwhile taubenberger had been
contacted by a retired pathologist named
dr
johann halton and halton had actually
beaten duncan
and taubenberger to the punch by almost
50 years
as a young graduate student in 1949 he
had also become intrigued by that
elusive 1918 virus and became determined
to find it in fact he decided to make
the virus the subject of his
dissertation
he tracked down a mass grave of 72 flu
victims in brevik mission alaska
in 1951 but the expedition was a failure
he found several bodies but he was
unable to recover any of the virus
46 years later 1997
he read an article in science by
taubenberger and decided to try
digging at revig once again
so while the world was watching kirsty
duncan dr hulton flew back to brevik
checked into a local motel and began
digging for new samples with his pickaxe
most of the bodies that he found were
very badly decayed but there was one
obese victim dubbed lucy who was fairly
well preserved
heavy layers of fat around her lungs had
protected them
and hulton was able to collect several
tissue samples
he sent the infected frozen samples to
the army pathology lab
through ups the u.s post office and
fedex
those were the days well this time
halton was successful
and lucy yielded several viral fragments
toppenberger used these samples
together with the army samples that he
had collected to sequence
several of the viral genes
although we solved one mystery finding
intact genes from the 1918 virus
several mysteries remain unsolved
why did the flu kill so many young
adults
why were the three waves of flu so
closely spaced
and where did it come from
to this day no one knows why the flu hit
young adults so heavily
producing that w shaped curve we talked
about rather than the usual u-shaped
curve of mortality
so instead of that normal decline in
deaths
in young adult in early adult stages the
15 to 34 age groups in the 1918 flu show
a big spike
of mortality
well it may be that the healthy immune
systems of those young men and women
were their undoing and that's a novel
concept
can there be such a thing as being too
healthy
remember that the sheer devastation of
the lungs of soldiers was comparable
to the damage done by mustard gas
some doctors think this damage was
partly due to a deadly overreaction by
the immune system what we call
a cytokine storm
maybe the cytokine storm was
particularly intense
in those that had the healthiest immune
systems
or perhaps young adults in 1918 had
especially high levels of tuberculosis
leaving their damaged lungs ripe for
invasion by influenza
the unbridled virulence of the flu
probably contributed to its ultimate
undoing
flu is driven by herd immunity it needs
to constantly hop from one population to
the next
as each host population either dies or
acquires resistance
so we would expect to see waves of flu
spaced several months
apart major antigenic shifts would be
required every two or three years to
survive herd immunity
but the three waves of the 1918 flu were
very close together
each wave should have been months apart
but in some areas the three waves of the
flu were only weeks apart
and in a few places the waves were so
close together
it's hard to say where one ended and the
next one began
in the northern hemisphere the first
wave lasted from spring into summer
the second wave from summer to fall and
the third wave from fall to winter
and that tight spacing remains a mystery
to this day
it lends some support to the argument
that that second wave was a hybrid virus
or a mutant strain because a hybrid or
mutated flu would be sufficiently
different to overcome the partial
immunity of survivors of the first wave
cycles of the 1918 flu are so out of
step that
many scientists have come to doubt the
validity of the whole idea
of epidemiological cycles at least where
the flu is concerned
maybe the patterns formed by the
hypermutable virus
are just too unpredictable
or perhaps we're missing a much larger
pattern
one hypothesis suggests that h1 h2
and h3 flu strains are macrocycling
competing with one another in cycles
that can last
68 years or more
there are three types three genera of
flu
type a type b and type c
type a is the most dangerous it infects
humans and other mammals including pigs
and birds type b infects humans
and seals feels sorry for the little
guys
and type c infects humans and pigs
each type can have many subtypes and
each subtype can have several
variants remember those h spikes and n
spikes on the flu virus that we learned
about in lecture 11
well there are 16 known subtypes of the
h antigen
and nine known subtypes of the n antigen
flus prior to 1957 are designated
subtype h1n1
so the 1918 flu was h1n1
the 1957 pandemic was caused by a new
subtype
h2n2 which left 2 million people dead
the 1968 hong kong flu was h3n
and it left 1 million dead in its wake
we think that both the h2n2 and h3n2
subtypes are a mixture
of bird and pig flu genes
the molecular evidence suggests that the
1918 flu was h1n1
a novel strain of bird flu which later
spread to swine and humans
now there are no known records of
epidemics among poultry at that time but
ironically
bird flues are usually asymptomatic for
birds they carry it
but they don't suffer from it in the
wild we think
ducks are the natural reservoir and
we've taken samples of avian flu from
preserved wild birds and museum
collections and
they turn out to be very similar to the
ones we collect today
but the 1918 flu well that's a different
kind of avian flu
remember our earlier discussion of
competitive exclusion
flu is rather unusual and that new
subtypes of flu tend to drive
all of the old subtypes into extinction
only one subtype at a time usually
exists in humans and
usually only one variant
the reason may be that each new subtype
provokes a general immune response to
the flu virus
and that gives partial immunity against
a variety of other variants of the flu
including older strains
so when the older strains finally cycle
back into fresh populations
the door may already be closed
the 1976 swine flu was an h1n1 variant
which is why it caused an international
panic
nobody likes to get a flu shot but in
1976
a record 40 million of us lined up to do
just that i was one of them
along with president gerald ford
private david lewis a fresh recruit at
fort dix new jersey was the first
to die of the flu he collapsed in the
middle of a five mile hike
well flu had been spreading through the
barracks for weeks but no one up to that
point had died from it
only four of the many flu victims at
fort dix had that unknown swine flu
virus
and of those four only private lewis
died
but because the fatal flu turned out to
be h1n1 it revived fears of the 1918
pandemic
and that was enough to push the red
panic button
once the military released the story
about the fort dix outbreak the press
ran
wild assuming all of the horror stories
of the 1918 pandemic
and that publicity prompted the u.s
health service to call for a mass
vaccination
with a little tested vaccine
many people died or experienced severe
medical problems after getting their flu
shots
was it merely a coincidence or was the
vaccine
actually dangerous by may of 1980
over 3917
lawsuits had been filed seeking over
three and a half
billion dollars in damages
300 people died of the flu vaccine
according to the lawsuits
but only private lewis is known to have
died of the flu
well if nothing else that 1976 swine flu
scare prepared us for another
epidemiological nightmare
a modern outbreak or a terrorist attack
with weaponized flu
would require a similar scheme of mass
inoculation
in 1997 an explosive outbreak of avian
flu broke out in hong kong
this was a new strain of bird flu called
h5n1
and the sheer savagery of this new virus
led to a renewed urgency to understand
that doomsday flu
one and a half million chickens were
slaughtered to stop that disease in its
tracks
six out of 18 infected people died
and that could have been the beginning
of a serious new pandemic
but rapid quarantine and the destruction
of every single chicken in hong kong
stopped it in its tracks
h5n1 is currently the most dangerous
type of flu in circulation
and many experts think that if this bird
flu ever manages to fully cross over
into humans it would kill
untold millions of people the h5n1
mortality rate
now stands at 59 percent
march 2005 h5n1 broke out in vietnam
in indonesia and in north korea adding
still more victims
since 1997 295
people have died from h5n1
the full designation is actually hpai
ah5n1 the hp standing for
highly pathogenic and this form of flu
is epizootic which means it occurs in
non-human species
it's also panzotic which means that it
infects many different species of
animals
although it hasn't evolved yet to
efficiently cross over to humans
all the danger signs are there it's
lethal
it's spreading very rapidly through
avian populations and
it has already caused sporadic human
infections
flu expert robert webster says this
virus
right from scratch probably the worst
influenza virus in terms of being highly
pathogenic that i have ever
seen or worked with not only is it
frighteningly lethal to chickens
who can die within hours of exposure
swollen and hemorrhaging
but it kills mammals from lab mice to
tigers
with similar efficiency
a multi-billion dollar international
effort is currently underway to study
h5n1
and prepare for a possible future
outbreak
well why do so many strains of flu
continue to originate
in asia the most likely explanation is
the large number of people
living in close proximity to
domesticated pigs
and birds which is a recipe for a new
pandemic
between 1968 and 2004
china went from 5.2 million pigs to 508
million pigs
and from 12.3 million poultry to 13
billion poultry so was the 1918 flu an
asiatic flu some think it might have
begun as an avian virus in china
and many agree that that killer flu or a
very close relative
caused some mild local epidemics in 1916
and 1917.
we mentioned the likelihood of kansas as
a point of origin in humans
but a recent paper by john oxford claims
that it first
erupted in a massive field hospital
complex in etopla in northwest france
in the winter of 1915 and 16.
symptoms were very similar to those of
the subsequent pandemic
was the 1918 flu a swine flu or an avian
flu
tovenberger was originally certain that
the 1918 flu virus came from american
pigs
but his latest research demonstrated
that in fact it was an avian flu
flu expert robert webster claims that it
was definitely swine flu
and probably circulating in mammals for
some time before 1918
but taubenberger remains unconvinced
pointing out that the swine flu
was not described by veterinarians prior
to 1918.
gavin smith in the 2009 paper in nature
hypothesized that the virus was actually
a blend of both avian flu
and swine flu pigs can catch both human
and avian flu and that makes them a
veritable viral blender
so the 1918 flu might have been part pig
part bird
and part human h1n1
has become one of the most common causes
of respiratory disease in pig farms
in north america hence that swine flu
designation for h1n1
despite the fact that it may ultimately
come from birds
the 2009 swine flu epidemic was an h1n1
subtype like the 1918 flu which is one
reason why doctors overreacted so
strongly to that outbreak
but initial analysis of the 2009 swine
flu pandemic
indicated a higher mortality rate for
young adults
just like the 1918 flu and once again
caused by extreme
cytokine storms
in 2004 a team from the university of
wisconsin at madison
took two genes from the 1918 flu virus
the ones that code for the h and the n
spikes and they stitch them
into the genes of mice they created
special strains with both genes or with
just the 1918
h or n genes the spliced n gene
all by itself proved to be relatively
benign nothing special
but that mutated h-binding protein whoa
that proved to be one of the primary
factors
that made the 1918 flu so incredibly
virulent
that same team in 2008 found a key set
of three genes from the 1918 virus that
allowed it to target cells in the lungs
rather than just the usual upper
respiratory cells that flu viruses would
ordinarily attack
in 2005 taubenberger's team announced
they had
finally decoded the entire genome of the
1918 flu
they used the army specimens preserved
in paraffin
and fragments recovered from halton's
lucy and concluded that it was an
avian virus that had found a new host in
humans
well whether pig or bird or human or
a combination of all three if that 1918
flu does
return we may be prepared for it this
time
terrence tumpy's team in 2006
spliced genes from the 1918 bug into a
modern
virus a living virus he then tested an
experimental dna vaccine that had been
developed by the nih
and found it to be effective against the
live reconstructed 1918 virus
mice were infected with the lab bug all
died
but all of the 10 vaccinated mice
survived
and so we've seen mankind on both the
winning side
and the losing side in our age-old
struggle with microbes
we conquered the germ of laziness but we
were decimated by the 1918 flu
and as we'll learn in our next four
lectures there's a very good reason
why we've managed to survive the
evolutionary arms race so far
our highly evolved immune system gives
us a deadly weapon to use
against our microscopic rivals